حتى وقت ليس ببعيد كانت لورين باول فاعله
خير وزوجه رجل مهم حتى ان اسمها قلما ذكر
اعلاميا لكنها اليوم واحده من اعلام رياده
الاعمال في امريكا واحدى النساء الاكثر
ثراء في العالم مع بلوغ ثروتها اكثر من 13
مليار دولار فما سر هذه الثروه
ولدت لورين باول عام
1963 في نيوجيرسي وعاش الطفوله قاسيه حيث
فقدت والدها الذي كان يعمل طيارا في حادث
طائره وتزوجت والدتها مره اخرى حملت لورين
طموحات كبيره لتنميه ذاتها حيث التحقت
بجامعه
وحصلت على البكالوريوس في العلوم السياسيه
والاقتصاد عام
بعد تخرجها امضت لوريس ثلاثه سنوات بالعمل
في وول ستريت كخبير استراتيجي التجاريه ثم
عملت مساعده اداريه في شركه ميرالنج
للحلول الاستثماريه قبل ان تلتحق بجامعه
ستانفورد للحصول على ماجستير اداره
الاعمال خلال احدى محاضراتها الجامعيه
التقت لورينج ستيف جوبز احد اكبر الاسماء
في عالم المال والتكنولوجيا لتصبح زوجه
ذلك الثري وتتجه بوصلتها المهنيه نحو
الاعمال الخيريه عملت لورين لدعم فرص
التعليم المدرسي والاكاديمي من خلال
العديد من المنظمات غير الربحيه
ومبادره اسبالو التو كما عملت ايضا في
المجلس الاستشاري ليداستي الذي يوفر فرص
تعليم رمزيه التكلفه للطلاب وقامت بتاسيس
منظمه امرسن كولكتف وهي شركه استثمار
وعامل خيري تركز على العداله البيئيه
والصحه وتحديات الهجره والتعليم في عام
2011 فجعت لو
بسبب سرطان البنكرياس فقررت العوده الى
عالم الاستثمارات لاداره الارث العائلي
الذي تتشاركه مع ابنائها كانت لورين قد
ورثت عن زوجها صندوق ستيفن بيجوز الذي
يعرف حاليا باسم لورين باول جوبستراست
وكانت تبلغ قيمته انذاك اكثر من سبعه
مليارات دولار كما ورثت خمسه ملايين
من شركه
ما جعلها ثالث اغنى امراه في الولايات
المتحده وخامس اغنى امراه في العالم انذاك
في عام 2017 استثمرت لورين في شركه
الاعلاميه ومن ثم في منافذ اعلاميه اخرى
كما اسهمت في استثمارات عده في النشاط
الرياضي ثم ساهمت بتاسيس شركه الاطعمه
الطبيعيه تيرا فيرا في عام 2020 اليوم
وبعد ان كانت طالبه علم
تقدم لورين نفسها للمجتمع كمستثمره ناجحه
وناشطه مجتمعيه وراعيه لاعمال الخير
والتعليم مع ثروه تقدر بنحو 13 مليارا
ومئه مليون دولار
[موسيقى]